imagine waking up one day and all of the
women in the world had just disappeared
all but one may be the only woman left
on earth is you whether you're the only
woman or one of the many guys how would
your life change with this last woman
have all the power or none and how would
that affect the world that is a great
question
this is what if and here's what would
happen if all but one woman disappeared
from the face of the earth
the first reaction would be grief
everyone would have lost someone there
would also be chaos women make up 47
percent of the workforce in the United
States if they all skipped one day of
work at the same time the US economy
would lose approximately 21 billion
dollars that's just one day but what
about you
how would your everyday life change
[Music]
if you're a man you might have to step
up your game and skills that are
stereotyped does women's work while
women are working away from home more
than ever with 29 percent of married
women in the u.s. making more money than
their husbands women still take on more
household duties child-rearing cooking
and cleaning our tasks many women are
still expected to perform because of
gender stereotypes on a typical day in
the US 83 percent of women will spend
time on household activities while only
65 percent of men do the same but
without women around all those tasks
would fall on your shoulders that would
be a steep learning curve for some men
you'd also have no female companionship
just pause and think about that for a
moment you'd be surrounded by other men
all of the time your friendships and
family structure would change strict
gender norms might begin to dissolve
because men would have to take on all
rules and your love life we definitely
take a hit but what if you're the last
woman what would life be like for you it
would be lonely
you could have plenty of male friends
and as many dates as you wanted but no
female companionship
you know to balance things out you'd
also have to repopulate the world if you
had 20 years of fertility left then
there would only be 20 new humans in 20
years giving birth every year would
become your life's work probably not so
enjoyable it would be much quicker to
harvest your eggs and use artificial
wombs to repopulate the planet this
process is called ecto Genesis and in
April of 2017 researchers at the
Children's Hospital of Philadelphia Ann
they had developed an artificial womb
they called a bio bag this bio bag was
successful in animal trials using Lambs
scientists in the Netherlands claim they
are 10 years away from creating an
artificial womb suitable for human
babies but so far these bio bags are
only feasible for prematurely born
babies the initial gestation or the very
beginning of a baby's development in a
womb still has to be within the mother's
womb having only one woman left on earth
would motivate scientists to develop a
usable artificial womb while there are
many ethical questions around ecto
Genesis in this extreme situation it
might be our best hope and it would
relieve you the only woman on earth from
the physical exertion and risk of
repeated pregnancies but as the last
woman would you have more power or less
you would be the only person on the
planet who could produce new life that's
a pretty powerful position but you'd be
the only one who could speak up for your
gender which means your opinion could
easily be outvoted maybe leaving you
feeling very oppressed misunderstood and
a little more than angry every single
birth would be an international
celebration especially if the newborn is
a female and those kids as they grow up
would be the ultimate celebrities but it
could also be dangerous for females as
they begin to come of age in China and
India men currently own number women by
about 70 million the effect of this
has been a rise in violence human
trafficking prostitution and depression
so we would have to make sure any
repopulation effort would prioritize the
safety of all females born globally the
world would likely be a difficult and
lonely place without women so take a
moment to consider how important and
strong the women in your life are let's
face it we'd have a much easier time if
there was only one man left on earth but
that's a story for another what if
[Music]